how do folks remember me John Lowe
family doctor time was when I took
pretty good care of the people
hereabouts was with him when they were
born when they died
try to make the years in between just as
healthy and happy as it could but I
don't get around here very much nowadays
I guess maybe you're wondering what I'm
doing here now well it's like this I've
been wanting to drop in on Plainville
again visit some of the folks so I want
to see how the old worlds getting the
law
let's look in on the Jones family see
how they're doing
you know the milchem they're your
neighbors could be yourselves this is
Henry Jones
Henry's a skilled mechanic down at the
McGregor to land by works
looks like he's reading something that
bothers him here's Sally and their baby
sally was married to Henry's oldest son
day he was with MacArthur in the Pacific
one of the Expendables he won't be
coming back
and here's my old friend there were a
Jones Henry's mother
I knew Debbie when she was in pigtails
still got that saucy gleam in her eye
though from that stubborn Tim forever
talking about the good old days just
won't give him to admit how much better
things are today hello hello hello
this is jolly Charlie again with a brand
new tune speak of moonlight turn that
thing off
now hear me Joe we like to read your
newspaper in peace let us enjoy our
radio alright alright mother anything to
keep the peace but it hurts that was my
favorite announcer and he always plays
the record gamma yes Fred
not everybody working today grade at the
high school Sally
dr. Johnson finishing up the students
physical examination they're going to
help too that comes for your high
spirits that thing off nobody can hear
me I said you're a merry as a cricket
cause Bill McGregor is gonna be with you
today now granny you know Bill has
nothing to do with it
Gracie is there because she loves her
what no yes I suppose it's just one of
those things
Gracie taking a job in a hospital where
Bill's an intern you know very well I
like my job granny it's swell being a
part of such wonderful work and those
health records I've been keeping of the
school kids exam that's health in the
bank granny they pay real dividends well
I do too care part of the examinations
for is to some kind of an epidemic in
town goodness no we don't wait for
epidemics granny we try to prevent them
well in my day we didn't go to a doctor
until we were really sick that's just
the point you can't tell whether or not
you're really sick that's up to the
doctor that girl has a lot of sense
mother you shouldn't belittle her
interest in their work late again Peter
okay okay I make it we have a date this
afternoon haven't we Dickie boy we're
gonna go to the clinic and see that
everything is all right
every little finger and toe and I hear
that new too
I think it's all stuff and nonsense
taking the baby to the clinic every
month if he were my baby I've never
taken there at all being pawed over and
bounced around by a lot of doctors and
nurses all sorts of people why don't you
go down to the clinic and see for
yourself what it's like granny Oh me
Deborah Joe go to a minute
watch it granny you'll get high blood
pressure
I think salad smart to watch out for the
baby's health like she does your good
think we all did it I was just reading
here a hundred and sixty thousand people
die of cancer every year some of these
deaths are the result of people going to
quacks for treatment some because they
don't go to an accredited doctor until
too late but cancer can be cured if it's
treated in time and by the approved
methods of surgery x-ray and radium and
it says that tuberculosis and a lot of
other diseases can be cured if they're
discovered early enough people certainly
ought to go to the doctor we didn't go
looking for trouble in my baby no mother
you didn't and that's why so many died
before their time I still think when it
comes time for a person to die they die
there's just nothing anybody can do
about it oh I wouldn't say that Debra if
I had known what doctors know now I
might have been able to save your baby
the one that died of diphtheria nowadays
de faria toxoid is saving thousands of
lives every year Debra Jones stop
gulping those pills and listen to me
Sally believes in prevention and deep
down in your heart you know she's right
only you're too darn stubborn to admit
it
I'm not stubborn they said you were
mother what's the matter granny why
nothing's the matter what should be the
matter mind your babies Sally I've got
to be going
goodbye if you both two food like that
young man you'll need one of my
digestion pills joy go Danny there's a
breakfast like this under my belt
nothing will hurt me don't be impudent
and don't talk with your mouth full
don't forget to show up for your
physical at school this morning and get
your chest x-ray report okay hey sis did
you see that x-ray report was it all
right
I'm so glad to see you taking an
interest in your help
all right don't care anything about my
health I just want to be old for
football bingo for football isn't being
healthy Oh certainly not
hello yes darling I'm just leaving now
yes I'll be right over the mother and I
are a bit worried about dad I want to
drop off of the plan see how he's
feeling
all right there
bye-bye
don't worry about it father who's going
to get the plaid doctor to tell him the
idea of a checkup
I hope it's nothing serious I hope not
I'll that's bill about us when I see him
I'll have to run along me too goodbye
mom
Oh Sally I left the health cap that you
wanted over there oh well have a good
day
you wouldn't want to come to the clinic
with deke and me today would you now
Sally don't start that again
by the way Sally as your baby had its
diphtheria shot or whatever you call it
why of course he has what made you ask
glad I was just remembering maybe if
you've read about what's going on that
tub pamphlets left me funny
I'm sure she left it here so we just
picked it up guess that's why folks
leave mind about just a temp people
stubborn who's stubborn know what can be
the matter with granny
I'll tell you the man who is granny is
that the old hardshell seems to be
softening up a bit she's always been so
sure of herself
but it isn't her pills that keep her
going is the walk she takes the food
cheats the cab that she has after lunch
too bad I can't give granny a for
attitude now for a look at the younger
generation here's a mighty fine school
Health Service these Plainville doctors
are certainly doing a grand job periodic
checkups like these give them a chance
to prevent illness instead of half a
chance to cure it
bright youngster this but lately she's
been falling behind in her work now the
mystery solved Jane needs glasses
Tommy once had rheumatic fever growing
pains some folks call it but the wise
ones like Tommy's mother send for the
doctor net why Tommy's all right now
bill McGregor is responsible for a
mighty important part of the checkup
teeth certainly get a lot of care these
days and that says it should be an our
young friend Peter Jones wonder if
you'll make out all right everything's
fine Pete and the chest x-ray - I'm glad
to see you weren't worried about it some
of the other boys are out a positive
tuberculin test
I don't excited why should I get excited
you told me that didn't mean I had TB
just that I needed a chest x-ray to make
sure
good boy Pete I wish everyone would
listen to us carefully and get the facts
right so I can go out for the team you
said me cam
too bad Grandpa Jones didn't live to see
Peter make the team but grandpa died of
TV didn't even know he had it until it
was too late
and then O'Brien Joe Fenton and Sam
Karski as many members as chairman of
our new Health and Safety Committee you
have elected Henry Jones all of you men
get behind your committee and let's put
this Health Program over with a bang
Howard Jones
oh yeah doctor
it's a real job and I know you can
handle it let's go and see the big boss
we have a date to talk things over and
I'd like you to come along and give us
your idea fine just a minute all right
take off over there you know I think
we've got something doctor glad you feel
that way doctor looks like my lunch box
that's vitamin glamour my boy right in
thank you our new health committee
chairman mr. McGregor yes I just heard
congratulations Jones Thank You mr.
McGregor I'll do the best I can
won't you sit down gentlemen the Health
Department have notified me they can
move in their equipment for chest x-ray
next week how about it mr. McGregor fine
I think a chest x-ray is the safety
devices every man needs our plant has a
record for working conditions less
absenteeism from illness and injury than
most in these masts x-rays doctor
stewardess everybody get to know the
other fellas business the boys wouldn't
like that
no the reports are confidential like all
the medical examinations in this plan
another thing the x-rays are freeze of
the men and made on company time to hell
in that case I'm sure the boys will be a
hundred percent for it I wonder if you
could give us some sort of Health
pamphlets and things like that that we
couldn't hand around this table oh yes
sure we can get plenty of good
information free like those leaflets
from the tuberculosis Association you
know they are working very closely every
step of the way with the Health
Department we can get movies too and
transcriptions for the loudspeakers any
other ideas
I'd like an occasional half hour on the
company time for a health talk to the
men well I feel sure the board will
grant that request I'll take it up on
them another thing
but I call an ambulance Jones and I'll
operator call an ambulance quickly yes
don't worry dad you're going to be
alright tell me I have coronary heart
trouble what does that mean coronary
heart trouble
well without getting too technical it
simply means that your coronary arteries
are hardened up a bit when that happens
the heart muscle gets less blood not
enough food and oxygen too old man that
won't make 48 you're in the prime of
life but this kind of heart trouble hits
hardest at men around your age come on
stop no course not but you're gonna have
to stay right where you are for a while
and obey orders it's not going to be
quick and it's not going to be easy to
get you back on your feet again you've
got to get your mind off the plan and
stop worrying
cheer up young fellow you got all the
specialists in the hospital
and your own son to the gap you remember
now take it easy
yes bill your dad's a pretty sick man
but we know he's not fighting alone and
he knows it too bill and you've got this
up-to-date hospital with it
modern blood bank it's life-saving
medicine new as today's arrivals
physical therapy at its latest and best
all important laboratory service
xray that looks inside the body and
takes the guesswork out of diagnosis
skilled hands and brains discipline
teamwork ready for any emergency
how's your father bill it's going to be
a long hard pool Gracie I'm sure he'll
be all right
he's always been so healthy I don't know
much about medicine please don't think
I'm just being a little dumbbell you're
being just swell Gracie it means a lot
having you here with me now you know I'm
glad I can be here close to you and your
father when you mean so much to me bye
that's granny going into the clinic with
Sally and the baby
this is mrs. Deborah Jones nurse Dickies
great-grandmother this is her very first
visit to the clinic and I persuaded her
to come it was a tough fight but we made
it dr. Johnson's ready to see you now
mr. Jones you may go in granny you mean
you actually made an appointment here
before we even talked about coming
you don't think a snip of a girl like
you could persuade me to do something I
hadn't the mind to do I've persuaded
myself maybe it was that voice that's
been whispering to boy you wouldn't know
it was someone long before your time
what are you going to have done
what's the matter great nothing's the
matter I'm gonna have a general checkup
I guess I can have one if everybody else
the town's having one I'm not as
stubborn as you think but I never said
you weren't granny yes it's a wonderful
thing this
no wonder the people of Plainville are
using it more and more including granny
but Sally knew about it all along
Dickies the healthy proof of that
do you take your baby regularly to the
position or the well-baby clinic yes has
every member of your household had a
recent physical examination including a
chest x-ray yes even granny
Dicky's one may be well protected
against disease he's going to be healthy
wealthy and wise
are you doing granny they tell me I'm
doing alright Peter but I always knew
that it won't catch me winding up with
too little too late
it had happened to me
I'm doing all right that you are Deborah
when an old diehard like you sees the
light it proves nobody's ever too old to
learn
you know doctors have found out a lot of
new things since my day 30
nowadays they can prevent illness of
course they can't do it alone
they must have your help that's why the
ones who give me hope are the young
folks greats and Bill Sally and young
Peter they're learning that health is a
personal responsibility and they're
doing something about
and healthy kids it's like that young
dick
they guarantee this old world new lease
on life
well it's a panic we getting along now
yeah that gift you want a boy